does Demi Lovato's ex hold the key to
her heart and her sobriety after
suffering her near deadly overdose in
July our et source says quote sobriety
is the most important thing in Demi's
life right now adding that Dewey's
mother and her ex Wilmer Valderrama have
visited her in rehab when they can I
knew I loved them when I met him he's my
best friend
the couple's split in 2016 after a
six-year relationship but remained close
in the years since I've never loved
anybody like I loved Waller and like I
still love him last year in her
documentary simply complicated Demi
described him as her first and only true
love and he merits
always with well could you not share six
years with somebody and not give them a
piece of your heart
[Music]
earlier this year at Wilmer told VT how
much he respected her ability to be so
honest about her struggles she's a hero
man she's a retired too young to young
men and women out there she's literally
the image of a recovery
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]